you got these kids what kind of things
be like with them how do you take them
to the play soccer do they I think
you'll get this common I think you'll
understand this I am my favorite spot is
um I don't know if everybody knows what
this is Color Me Mine
come on Iman I know what that is yeah
sure that's you got a yeah my friend
Greg Daniels made me this at Color Me
Mine yeah yeah see Color Me Mine is a
place where you just slap some paint on
some pottery and glaze it up and it's
beautiful I take my kids all the time
kids love it that kids love it and so do
rob corddry 'he's okay but the kids
they'll just like take little things and
there's a slap pink paint on it be like
blah next fun thing what right and it
looks like someone just vomited color on
it yeah and I'm like just you know
serious in the corner working with a
tiny brush it's like I got when I finish
with this brown like I'd be gone
yesterday if you guys hadn't taken all
the pink for this breast so you you're
very type-a about coloring your Color Me
Mine right yours in its type a I would
say that's like I'm an artist perhaps I
was so supposed to go there for the kids
you know so they say but they're like I
actually couldn't finish it I had to go
back I dragged the kids to the place
that is for kids so I could finish my
Thanksgiving turkey I think you brought
it with you you've got a picture that is
a beautiful you did a really nice job
thank you
gorgeous thanks Connor I call that I
call that piece color me a genius all
right will Children's Hospital hilarious
show Thank You
airs Friday nights at midnight on Adult
Swim and you guys are pushing the
envelope on that show I will tell you
don't give us an envelope don't give me
one right now I'll push it right out of
here push it right off the stick
you